what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so as we pick up with Supergirl
rebirth I was trying to time this around
the same time as the episode of
Supergirl that came on as part of the
invasion because I don't know if you
guys saw that episode or not but it was
amazing like I had one hell of a time
watching it I don't know I really liked
Supergirl on CW I felt like when it was
on CBS whatever it was before it was
taking itself too seriously I like the
vicious kind of it's a show about a
superhero like I like that they're fully
embracing that I think it really works
for her character and what she's about
but the idea here with Supergirl rebirth
is this is actually DC kind of returning
things to familiarity because if those
are guys you don't know when DC launched
the new 52 and they introduced the
newest iteration of Supergirl a lot of
fans hated it because it wasn't the
Supergirl they were used to you got to
keep in mind you know Kara zor-el as we
knew her had effectively died in 1985
during crisis on Infinite Earths and so
because of that we got like Lynda
Danvers we got some knockoff versions
but it wasn't the true Kara's or another
reason for that was because you know
crisis on Infinite Earths instead of
standard for a lot of different things
and one of them was to return Kara
zor-el I guess returns Superman to being
the sole survivor of Krypton and so it
did make any sense to turn around and
introduce a Supergirl if Superman was
supposed to be the last Son of Krypton
and so because of that you know we never
really saw any real very variation of
her character now we did get her in the
new 52 the problem was that Supergirl
was always this cheery character she was
always designed to be vibrant and
exciting and fun
but in the new 52 she was just very emo
she was angry at the world and so
because of that fans didn't really care
for it too much and it's not only been
able to tell you know doing some surfing
around and looking at some some various
stories and so on
what DC did is when they were setting
the the standard for the launch of DC we
berth we of course knew that as for our
Superman was concerned this dealt with
his powers being wound down to the point
where he was almost powerless and it was
all part of a larger story or at least
truth was it was part of a larger a
larger story arc in order to remove
Superman from the new 52 and replaced
him with a pre new 52 Superman now in
terms of Kara zor-el this affected her
as well you know for the Supergirl
character it affected her just like it
did Superman the reason why is during
the story arc I think it was Superman
doomed what he was possessed by the
doctor by the doctor doom when he was
possessed by the doomsday entity which
is kind of a new 52 reimagining of his
concept it resulted in the fact
a Superman and doomsday were effectively
the same being and so what happened was
the atmosphere was essentially polluted
with a kryptonite dust that ended up
operating as somewhat of a chemotherapy
a source for the Superman character in
the sense that he was able to eliminate
the doomsday concept and then revert
back to his normal self the problem with
this was that it also took away the
powers of anybody who was kryptonite
in effect Kara zor-el and so what DC did
is they used this as a way to circle
back around to DC rebirth and reimagine
her as the young upbeat and vibrant
character that we all knew and so there
are some things that stayed consistent
here in the sense that this is the new
52 Supergirl the difference here is that
she's not 24 anymore she's 16 now you
know she's young she's exciting she's
not you know angry at the world because
no one really seems to understand her
and so we're picking up with this we
actually jump back to the days of Argo
city now this is kind of a weird
situation because we're not it was as
far as I can tell we're not explicitly
told if this is before or after
Supergirl was sent away but as far as I
can tell it was before she was even born
but the idea here is that Argo city is
still under the control of her father of
zor-el and the idea here is that one of
the last surviving Kryptonians on Argo
city suffering from red kryptonite
sickness now in DC Comics red kryptonite
has a very very long history in fact the
first form of kryptonite introduced in
DC Comics was red kryptonite now that
version of red kryptonite was
essentially had all the same principles
as Green and it wasn't until later on
that we saw red kryptonite actually
imposing mutations but whenever a
Kryptonian is exposed to red kryptonite
it basically forces unchecked mutations
and no one really knows how they're
going to react to it which is why
whatever Superman is exposed to red
kryptonite he reacts to different ways
sometimes he might mutate into another
person sometimes his identities might
split you know sometimes he will totally
change and in terms of physical
appearance sometimes you lose all his
powers it really just kind of depends on
what the writers want to do is it's kind
of a MacGuffin in terms of how his
characters impacted here but because of
the fact that one of these Kryptonians
because Laurent is suffering from red
kryptonite sickness he's going through a
series of mutations that we don't know
what these mutations are but what we do
know is the response from Kara zor-el
father is to essentially lock him away
in the Phantom Zone and the Phantom Zone
is kind of this place where they just
store people who are either criminals or
individuals who are infected until they
can find a cure and that's the intention
here is to you know store him in the fan
zone until a cure can be found the
problem with this is that as we know you
know wallet was floating out in space
and while the the last you know
remaining citizens of Krypton were
trying to find a place to live our guru
City was effectively destroyed which
resulted in Kara zor-el being sent away
in a fashion very similar to Superman
and her landing on earth and so during
all this time Lauren was effectively
inside the Phantom Zone now from here we
again basically pick up with the
de-facto handlers or parents of Kara
zor-el at this point in time and what
they're doing is they're effectively
trying to restore her powers alongside a
woman named Cameron chase now Cameron
chase has been around since around 1988
I think she's been here for quite some
time and her role has changed in a lot
of different ways there was one point
where an athlete even the new 52 they
had her operating as head of the de o
the Department of extra-normal
operations and what she did here is she
worked in a fashion akin to a marvel
shield in a sense that it was the idea
of monitoring individuals who were here
on earth and may impose some kind of a
threat to their safety in and of itself
now in terms of Cameron chase s she
exists here right now there was actually
a bargain that was struck between
Cameron and Supergirl and we'll learn
more about this here later on but in the
middle of trying to restore her powers
the plan as it existed was like this
because Kara zor-el had essentially been
infected with a kryptonite dust that was
more or less permanent or seemed to be
permanent in removing her powers the
idea was to use a phantom drive and send
her to the Sun allowing her to absorb
the solar energies which in turn would
burn out this this kryptonite dust and
then would allow her to regain her
powers now in DC Comics a phantom drive
is quite literally what it sounds like
it's a Kryptonian device is essentially
like a warp core the difference is that
instead of folding space and time on
itself in the traditional sense it
basically allows the person who is
piloting a vessel that's powered by a
phantom drive to pass right through the
Phantom Zone and then take them wherever
it is they need to go so it's basically
that the same function in fashion as a
warp drive the difference is that the
manner in which you travel is a little
bit different than a traditional faster
than light speed engine or driver or
whatever you want to call it but the
idea here is that a she's on her way you
know to to the Sun we suddenly have
Lauren emerging because again you know
they essentially opened a portal to the
Phantom Zone and so it was really only a
matter of time before somebody or
something fell out of it now when he
comes out what he says is
that essentially night triggers his
mutations that's what causes him to
change now this is actually a little bit
of an inconsistency here as far as I can
tell in the sense that whenever a person
is exposed to red kryptonite it's
somebody idea that they change you know
they are they're modified they undergo
some kind of mutation and to the effects
of the red kryptonite we're off the
kicker with this and I guess it's not
really an inconsistency I guess it's
really a kind of a focus on his
character the kicker with this at least
it seems is that because he's been
poisoned with red kryptonite it's part
and parcel to his genes it's what makes
up who he is now Supergirl actually
figures this out here in a little while
but for the most part this is really
just you know Lauren in his you know
wolf type shape going through and just
attacking everybody that he finds and
it's really just you know creating this
the scenario where it's like will
Supergirl get there in time which of
course we know that she does and when
she when she gets there she immediately
begins taking it to Lauren and and
pummeling him as best she can now the
cool thing about this is the Supergirl
that we knew that we always loved you
know from a crisis on Infinite Earths
era from a four crisis on Infinite
Earths
she was very upbeat she was very
cheerful and this is the kind of
Supergirl that we get and that's what
DC's doing DC is telling us this is the
Supergirl you could expect to see in the
future of her comic books in the sense
that she doesn't show up lash out and
just start beating the hell out of
Laurent instead she starts trying to
talk to him trying to reason with him
say hey look I know you lost everything
Argo city's been destroyed you were in
the Phantom Zone I don't know why my
father did it I never met him I never
really knew anything about him aside
from whatever images that I saw through
kryptonite crystals when I was here but
aside from that I don't know everything
that's going on but what she does say is
if you are truly from Krypton then I'm
from Krypton as well we're effectively
family even if it's only on the genetic
sense you can trust me I will never let
you down and so because of that she's
able to sort of anchor you know this
this Leron character back to reality and
as a result he seems to recede back to
his normal self and then of course he's
taken prisoner by the by the de OU and
so again we basically learned that this
pact that was struck between Supergirl
and the de Oh was that Supergirl would
get her powers back
the DEA would help her to regain her
abilities in turn they would have like
she would help them and so it's
essentially a scenario whereby if some
kind of a bean shows up that threatens
the earth that threatens all life on
Earth Supergirl will step in not because
it's the superhero thing to do but
because she's working for the de oh now
in truth even if she wasn't working for
the de oh she would still step in
because she's a superhero that's what
she does I mean
kind of her theme because that's the
kind of character that we're getting now
in addition to this she also needs to
operate outside and in the normal sphere
of society you know she needs to be able
to have a normal life just because of
the fact that one it's a matter of
convenience but two it will also allow
her to gain a better understanding of
what's going on in the world to
reintegrate herself into society as a
normal human being but it also allow her
to put her ear to the ground and hear
things the eeo may otherwise not be able
to hear and so because of this she's
effectively given the the name of Kara
Danvers now if some people would have
looked at this and said well this is
essentially the Supergirl comic copying
the TV show not exactly there are some
similarities here but that's why this
works well because it's kind of a good
blend you know we would expect to see
like Kara zor-el but the idea that we're
seeing Kara Danvers the idea that we're
effectively seeing the namesake of you
know Supergirl as she exists in the TV
show provides us some measure of
familiarity without breaking her
character to the point that it's like a
comic adaptation to the TV show and so
again it all pretty much just sort of
works out here but in the last scene a
little bit of this we basically pick up
with the remnants of Argo city or at
least Argo city you know after it's been
destroyed and we effectively have you
know some guy that looks like cyborgs
Superman that looks like Hank Henshaw
for all intents and purposes and you
know he's basically talking about how
his actions or whatever it was that he
did had essentially led to the
destruction of Argo city and his people
and the goal is to effectively fix this
problem he keeps saying things like he's
going to do better this time
so on and so forth of course you know
this again leads into the current story
arc as it exists right now which I think
is wrapping up relatively soon but if
you guys are new here to come and
explain make sure you guys hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob port you guys enjoy this video drop
a like and yeah I need to tell you I'm
really digging what they're doing with
Supergirl right now like I'm really
enjoying how this is coming out but uh
yeah I will catch you all later peace
you